sybille merci mais non pierre marcotte a
connu l'âge d'or des émissions de
variétés au québec c'était une époque
merveilleuse et rire dans sa vie rire
rire à gorge déployée à tous les jours
de ta vie à mario guérin
durant les années 70 avec les talents
c'était une véritable star à télé
métropole
il faisait partie de notre quotidien ils
rentraient tous les jours dans nos
salons à travers la télévision et il
faisait rire les gens comment
voulez-vous pas l'aimer né à joliette le
25 novembre 1938 pierre marcotte entame
sa carrière à la radio dès l'âge de 16
ans à la télévision en plus des talents
pierre marcotte a co animé de nombreux
jeux questionnaires et plusieurs
émissions de variétés pierre
im/s un ferme le monde et ça c'est ça
qui fait la différence entre quelqu'un
qui est connu et quelqu'un qui devient
entre guillemets une vedette pour
admirer et mais passionné de musique et
l'oeil deux fils avec des chanteuses
jeunes et ravel et shirley théroux sur
sa page facebook cette dernière souligne
la kfw vient de tuer un autre grand
québécois que nous avons toutes et tous
aimé pierre reçu durant toute sa
carrière vous apporter de la joie et du
bonheur il vous a beaucoup aimé il avait
un très grand respect pour vous son
public d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
sociaux les réactions des admirateurs et
de la classe politique ont été
nombreuses en plus d'une carrière
prolifique à la radio et à la télévision
pierre martel a été le gestionnaire de
plusieurs entreprises dont le restaurant
hélène de champlain sur l'île sainte
hélène à montréal en 2016 il était monté
sur scène avec la tournée les tannants
c'est fou fou fou en compagnie de ses
complices de l'époque c'était une
personne qui en donnait beaucoup aussi à
son public une personne qui aimait
beaucoup son public qui était
respectueux envers son public qui est
fort généreux
il devait d'ailleurs faire un retour sur
les planches cet automne au casino
montréal mais là que vivent 19 en a
décidé autrement il est mort simplement
il a faim facetime avec ses deux fils
sable on est à côté
psg garde dans les rangs du lol tenir
était dans la chambre a pris son
cellulaire d'approché de l'oreille de
pierre
puis j'ai dit pierre fait robert tu es
mon ami pour toujours je t'aime
et donner et je me dis il a ouvert les
yeux avec son décès c'est un chapitre de
l'histoire de la télé d'ici qui se
referme c'est comme si notre note notre
passé et notre époque s'en aller avec
ruby sénat mordent c'est la mort d'une
époque
ici n'est dit alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal